[Musik]
bekommen wir heute zu einem neuen blog
war meine damen und herren sprechen sind
eingeblendet jude und ich schaue heute
auf ihr bereit sind für ein baby dafür
werden wir nämlich heute im laufe des
tages irgendwann zu toys 'r' us fahren
und uns eine babypuppe kaufen aber nicht
irgendeine sondern so eine für irgendwie
200 euro die halt auch reden kann und so
ich weiß eigentlich ist es wieder wenn
man jetzt sagt okay hier freunde von
unserem kind denn die haben einfach
warum filmtag und passen auf und wir
gucken mal ob es mit dem baby gegen die
auch wieder mit klarkommen sowie die und
wieder das gemacht haben allerdings
eigentlich in unserem noch keine leute
in kent deswegen kaufen uns halt eine
puppe ich habe heute noch ein zweiter
termin wir müssen doch in die stadt
fahren allerdings bevor irgendetwas in
diesem blog wir heute überhaupt
passieren kann machen wir uns erst mal
[Musik]
ich hätte gern
bju
diese verfügten donald frühstück und
eingeschritten nachdem wir beim friseur
waren fahren wir übrigens auch direkt
mit allstars und kaufen die babypuppe
jetzt schon gespannt auf deinem baby
ich glaube dass ein jahr
das finde ich jetzt luca waren hat zu
einem termin
auf fünf minuten wir hatten euch zwar
sagen im blog
ich hab die nicht weggekippt werde
ich beim friseur ladies gentlemen haare
sind wir wieder megatrends banker und
verrat an der stelle wir beiden fahren
jetzt zu teuer ist und kauft uns dort
eine truppe weil wir immer noch schauen
wollen ob sie bereit wären für ein baby
es regnet übrigens gerade richtig
ekelhaft ihren köln geil stau in der
ganzen innenstadt warschau dann haben
wir uns verfahren dann kam dort eine
baustelle und jetzt ist dass der umweg
den gefahren die und 20 kilometer da
wirklich 40 minuten sind nicht besser
als andere kommen freunde und jetzt
geht's ab zum verkaufsraum wir müssen
beides
oder ich glaube das ist nicht so ganz
tollen mini aber ich weiß nicht ob das
zu dir passt zu dir wir sind ja nicht
gegen ein auto sondern
woher also wir müssen uns gedanken
machen ob wir einen kinderwagen kaufen
und vielleicht noch so ein bettchen was
allerdings als erstes wirklich brauchen
das diese puppe auf der suche nach einem
kind
haben wir hier so magic cent entdeckt
freunde ich weiß dass leute damit schon
vor monaten oder jahren videos gemacht
haben aber hättet immer bock dass sich
so das ist halt irgendwie substantive du
meinst dass der dass diese
kombinierbarer sand denn ich nass das
ist ein magischer sein und die geben
ihren daumen hoch also ich glaube ich
sollte dazu mein video machen habt ihr
lust auf das man weiß aber nicht
anlasten das leichter
wann endlich auch lebron
james tobin also hier ist baby born es
nick interactive puppe also die kann
wohl irgendwas hier sind auch noch
andere die das
wir brauchen erstmal eine puppe bevor
wir eine badewanne kaufen ich glaube nun
für einer die wir mit 23 jahren und zu
pumpen
[Musik]
2000 jahre später wir haben uns nach
langem überlegen endlich bei der benzin
und zwar juli die baby annabell zapf
creation
als baby entschieden es kam gerade zum
kind für jule und wie kann das an und so
von innen so genommen die schule mit
ihrer mutter verwechselt da vorne steht
somit haben wir mit unserem kleinen baby
oder gar keinen namen
das ist aber sehr einfallslos aber okay
sie heißt annabelle dies wünschen jetzt
zur großen kamera das heißt die qualität
wird um einiges besser sein ton wird um
einiges besser sein und dann schauen wir
mal was diese aller welt alles so schön
kann also
jule luca
annabelle
mag mich lieber
ich kann es unser kind nicht mögen dazu
ist jetzt also die liebe annabelle wir
haben ja gerade schon batterien hinten
gepackt das heißt er ist eben einfach
mal auf
sich annabel also jude meist gerade dass
die jetzt was zum trinken braucht
als hätte ich das wirklich liebe
wichtige sich das ist ja auch unser baby
also
was geht ab mit diesem ding gut passen
auf dass du nicht kriegen wie weil wir
haben uns hier auf jeden fall noch
windeln mit dazu gegeben das heißt wir
müssen jetzt erstmal will also zunächst
einmal würde ich sagen ihnen wie immer
das getränke aus und ihr seht wirklich
freuen ich weiß immer das hier sieht ich
glaube schon die hat die wirklich so
tropfen hängen auch also kommentiert die
tropfen richtig also diana welt wird
jetzt von der juli hier gerade gewickelt
das thema kurzen parma hierunter dann
seht ihr mal kurz die mama dass jemand
genau macht man tutorials
die ist einfach eingeschlafen was tust
du denn da juli
hallo
annabelle
mit seinem herzen eine seele werden sich
ihrer großen schwester sei also eine
anhaltung stand dass man die kleine anna
findet ihr auf jeden fall auch noch und
man ist das eingeklemmte jule in arbeit
statt dass man die hitze kann also
eigentlich also die kleine annabell ist
ausgezogen sie hatten den windel
umgestaltet wie habt ihr hier trinken
und
das heutige zentrum wir sind voll nette
eltern zu der internet steht oder witzig
wie der anleitung steht sogar dass man
mit der laufen kann also wir probieren
jetzt mal mit anderen laufen zu gehen
also hier ist die kleine annabell wir
haben hier vielleicht immer weggenommen
und hofft dass man sich so ein spieler
aus
aller welt damit glücklich ich glaube ja
da wird es einfach unmöglich weil sie
also nicht beweisen konnte dass die
laufenden als auch in der welt darf mit
dem bacardi endlich ist so genau und
jetzt setzte ein ich muss bei den
anderen
vielleicht muss ja auch erst krabbeln
mehr als aktuell beim krabbeln ist es so
dass die beiden schließlich hier hat
jetzt hast du die beiden armen hier und
jetzt klappt es so einfach so ganz leise
mal selber machen
manchmal selbst
übergeben kann ein
unternehmen nicht mitziehen hier
zurücksetzen die das ganze hier mann auf
genau
so
tragen die coolen mädchen münzen also
ist aber noch immer nicht wie die
anderen weltgegend aufgegeben haben weil
ich habe wirklich schon die halbe von
dieser flasche ihr ausgangspunkt
beigesteuert das wir zeigen hier die
sieht so aus also vielleicht hier auf
jeden fall schon getrunken aber ich weiß
nicht
ich meine in lord sie die augen auf ihr
trinkt doch da essen allerdings wissen
wir nicht wieder unten das rauskommen
sollte man das irgendwie
wir uns auf jeden fall irgendwie einen
knopf aber die annabelle was mich zu
diana welt erst mal ein bisschen
schlafen die annabelle bringen das ist
meine freude also gute nacht aller welt
gesehen und gleich wieder
die kann nicht mehr passen während die
andere bilder unten jetzt gerade ihren
schönheitsschlaf macht lassen wir die
leute erst mal 12 stunden liegen wie er
ist als erst mal eine kleinigkeit und
dann sehen wir andere gleich wieder und
schauen wir wie es ihr geht es
mittlerweile sind einige stunden
vergangen freunde es ist gerade haut vor
knochen allerdings würde ich sagen dass
wir etwas zusammen schauen diese der
anderen geht die hat er jetzt hier
gerade ein paar stunden in unserem
schlafzimmer gekämpft die jule ist
aber auch egal die brauchen wir nicht
jeder weiß dass ich das bessere
elternteil gespürt sagen wir sind jetzt
mal ein bisschen leiser freunde gehen
jetzt immer ganz langsam und schleichend
meint die frau davon liegt die annabelle
drin
[Musik]
red
so
was machst du denn um diese
dienstagabend hinter das tust du denn
uns umbringen warum wird schließt die
annabelle warum
warum schläfst du jetzt
die wand so lieb zu dir
ja ich meine ich dachte du kannst halt
schon laufen
wie oft kann dieses ding schlafen genau
jetzt erst mal wieder eine windel an
beruhigt dich mal ein bisschen machte
ein nickerchen würde ich sagen trinkst
du jetzt erstmals ein bisschen wodka
hier
das annabelle du kannst das ring
wir haben keine milch ich werde mich auf
jeden fall mal dafür interessieren alles
was
entweder ist sie bewusstlos oder sie
schläft schon wieder bewerben wird
gefunden das in der anleitung steht
bitte beachten sie dass die puppe selbst
kein wasser ansaugen kann deswegen ist
es erforderlich die flasche zu drücken
also füttern ja wer jetzt noch mal
richtig
baby annabell hat gerade angefangen zu
weinen
was ist denn mit der sind wir so scheiße
zu sehen wenn wir die ganze zeit heulen
die halbe menge wasser endlich das heißt
wir gehen jetzt damit ihr aufs treppchen
also freuen wir machen ja ich finde ihn
los und baby annabell geht jetzt mit uns
hier zusammen auf toilette gehen
ich würde sagen lassen baby annabell
jetzt erstmal ein bisschen raus blätter
die muss erst wenn die ganz nebenbei
holz sind natürlich auch schon wieder an
der stelle durch den heutigen berg ist
allerdings auf erden meine damen und
herren wir wollen das einfach mal so
eine kleine gruppe kaufen bisschen
schwarze mit der macht das ist natürlich
kein richtiger test ob wir gewartet sind
für babys und wenn wir natürlich auch
nicht das hier tun morgen kommt
irgendwie so zu besuch wir so auftreten
wie gefordert oder das gerne mal einen
like da ich hoffe euch gefallen wenn
nicht dann der doof ich habe das bei
ideen für den block der übermorgen
kommen soll auf einem kanal ich lade
jeden zweiten tag einen block hoch
freunde wenn man ihr könnt bei einer
umfrage jetzt hier abstimmen was ich
machen soll im nächsten blog
[Musik]